[Música]
ah
imagínatelo desnudos imagínate los
desnudos
se preguntarán por qué hay una taza
detrás de mí y sospecho que es uno de
los principales momentos en los que se
me apareció cierto mecanismo que adopté
casi durante toda mi vida hasta el día
de hoy de los planteos existenciales
creo que más grandes o más puntuales en
la vida son o es el porqué de las cosas
buscar el sentido de las cosas hacia
dónde voy qué es lo que tengo que hacer
yo en esta tierra y demás siento que
todo eso nos va cargando también como de
un poquito de ansiedad entonces yo traté
de resolverlo simplemente en focalizar
me en las ganas absolutamente en eso y
así de simple como suena simplemente en
lo que yo tenía ganas de hacer
trato comienza cuando a mí me gustaba el
chocolate cuando era chico mi hermana
cuando terminaba de acomodar la cocina
yo iba y dejaba la taza sucia en el
medio de la valla y claramente saben y
me decía gonza porque puede ser que cada
vez que se terminó de acomodar la cocina
me dejas la tacita y toda sucia como de
regalito no ve la bala
en el jugada la pones en un costado a mí
era una actividad muy sencilla pero que
ellos particularmente no me daban ganas
de hacerlo tuve que empezar a hacer de
todas maneras para evitar cierto daño
colateral
dentro de mi casa y aportar a la paz
general
ella me decía gonza además vas a tener
que entender a lo que en la vida no vas
a poder hacer sólo lo que vos tengas
ganas
lo cual a mí y yo comprendía su enojo
pero de todas maneras no me terminaba de
cerrar este concepto
un segundo de paciencia porque de verdad
que ya va a llegar algo de verdad
entonces yo que hacía la baratas a
simplemente para evitar que mi hermana
me rete así de simple aplicaba así
acción a basora lo que a mí no me daban
ganas como en este caso lavar la taza
para después evitar que mi hermana me
retes y ahora no soy una suerte de
neutralización hasta ahí y porque de
alguna manera eran las eventualidades
que tenía que afrontar a mi corta edad a
éstas de ese momento me pasó algo
también era muy desordenado era
particularmente desordenado y hoy en
contrapunto eso soy el día mentalmente
opuesto pues tengo una estructura que
por ejemplo el teléfono celular va en el
bolsillo derecho delantero si en mi caso
en el izquierdo van las llaves y atrás
va la billetera yo sé hace que si ahí no
están esos objetos lo perdí
si indefectiblemente se los doy por
perdido entonces no tengo que andar
revisando entre los almohadones del
sillón o los lugares donde por lo
general las cosas perdidas entonces de
alguna manera mira qué clarito que está
cabe ms ordenado para dejar de buscar si
hay se empezó a repetir ciertos patrón
de comportamiento que le empecé a
prestar atención y a partir de ahí todo
intenté llevarlo desde este lugar hay
una película que se llama slumdog
millionaire
quien quiere ser millonario se llama que
va de un niño muy humilde de la india
que tuvo que pasar 200 millones de
situaciones muy desafortunadas y él
estaba muy enamorado una nena fueron
creciendo juntos después por un motivo
la dejó de ver dejaron de estar
conectados entonces este chico
se terminó anotando en un programa de
preguntas y respuestas muy conocidos que
se llama de esa manera quien quiere ser
millonario y que pasó este chico durante
toda su vida y todas las adversidades
que tuvo que pasar fue capturando
herramientas de todas sus experiencias
tanto lindas como malas él iba avanzando
detrás del objetivo que era volver a
encontrarse con esta chica entonces se
anota en este programa de preguntas y
respuestas de cultura general y él tenía
toda esa respuesta simplemente por esto
de estar atento y tratar de capturar
todas las herramientas de todas las
actuaciones que iba pasando
tengan paciencia porque de verdad que
voy a llegar voy a llegar a algo de
verdad entonces empiece a crecer tenía
muchísimas ganas estudiar teatro por lo
que ella sentía que las condiciones no
iban a ser las mejores no era una
carrera exacta de hecho yo decía voy a
estudiar teatro cuando termine y me
decían que lindo pero él pero me dio vas
a estudiar algo también aparte porque no
era una situación en la que tampoco me
sentía cómodo pero de todas maneras yo
me focalicé en mis ganas en las ganas
realmente que tenía de conseguir ese
sueño que tenía hasta ahí de ser actor
pasando por todas las adversidades que
uno puede tener cuando también se tiene
que de su ciudad yo de hecho empecé a
estudiar este
actuación en malla blanca me tuve que ir
a buenos aires de hecho a mí iba yendo a
hacer cursos de a poquito pero realmente
era todo más difícil pero yo tenía toda
mi energía puesta en ese objetivo que
hasta en esa instancia de mi vida era
actuar entonces intentaba llevarme como
quien dice todo puesto para llegar hasta
ese lugar pasando la situación es que
iba a tener que pasar y tratando de no
renegar como por ejemplo las ganas que
tengo de salir de este círculo rojo
porque no se puede salir estoy acá
adentro de verdad
entonces estaban todas mis energías
expuestas en las ganas permanentemente
estoy aterrado de estar acá parado
delante de todos ustedes
de verdad de una situación de muchísima
exposición
y entonces lo que pasa es en ese
encuentro que pasa en este momento su
acción y digo tengo miedo si estoy me
siento súper expuesto por todas estas
miradas que están puestas en mí y en
este punto rojo que me dan ganas de
salir entonces una vez más se repite el
patrón accionó sobre algo que no me hace
sentir todo cómodo a corto plazo como
exponerme en poner en palabras esta
situación de incomodidad para resolver
esto que ahora me pasa que de repente
ahora sí me siento un poco más tranquilo
por haberme expuesto entonces una vez
más esto de accionar me va quizás a
resolver algo a futuro sí o por lo menos
traten toa lo que va sucediendo como el
chico de la película
estamos llegando a las capas que estamos
por llegar a algo
es la vida adulta llego como quien dice
termine de estudiar logré mi título de
actor me fui a buenos aires a vivir unos
amigos todo era un poco un desorden de
racing es porque sabes un poco entonces
nos pusimos a trabajar en una productora
muy muy grande que se llamaba la doble-a
era tan grande que tenía una célula que
era una casting era de a su casta y de
la propia para el recepcionista de la
cantinera ese pantalón base de camisa en
las estaciones la que ahora sólo había
soñado del todo pero sospechaba que de
alguna manera iba a llegar algo que me
pase un director por al lado y decirle
que soy actor
algo no importaba yo iba detrás de eso
porque además de alguna manera tenía que
financiar mi vida mi familia estaba
haciendo todos los esfuerzos para poder
es que yo esté ahí pero había que
reforzar por todos lados que me empezó a
pasar empecé a generar muchísima
confianza sobre todo en este esta suerte
de patrón que veía reflejado en
muchísimas acciones digo yo tengo que
hacer tengo que hacer y tengo que hacer
estaba haciendo los castings y me
gustaban mucho sacar fotos también
entonces un día
uno de los chicos que hacía cámara falta
y me dijo no me lo saca foto es una cosa
de esas puertas de hacer cámaras ya que
tiene renta el casting
voy a hacer cámara entonces me agarro
esa cámara me agarró de esa cámara por
una vez y entendí lo que podía llegar a
ser lo más cercano al cine y me enamoré
de esa profesión porque particularmente
es hermoso me voy a emocionar capaz un
poco pero realmente soy un poco sensible
con estas cuestiones genera muchísima
confianza me puse a hacer cámara o en
otro momento faltó el chico que dirigía
los castings y me dijeron bueno este
este teatro una equipada de esas porque
no te vas a dirigir es por favor el
casting porque tenemos 25 personas yo lo
hago fui yo puse dirigir el casting y
así pasaron muchísimas cosas
terminé dirigiendo publicidad me
hicieron director con mis 22 años me
impuso con sahagún ya que es un ser
humano que no voy hablar mucho de ello
de él iba a hablar pero me sensibiliza
un poco también por ese ser humano
intachable es el señor publicidad su
aprecio en publicidad ha hecho todo
desde la llama que llama delante
hicieron todo fue realmente muy
interesante casarme con él sobre todo
como ser humano como ejemplo de tipo y
de caballero era un que hoy por hoy
sigue siendo de mis mejores amigos
porque es un buen día les cuento un poco
entonces terminó dirigiendo publicidad
porque una vez más por este bendito
patrón yo me iba a hacer los making of
los backstage de los de los comerciales
cuando se ve la parte de atrás como se
hizo un comercial o una película
entonces por verme hay una persona un
director también amigo dijo cositas y
hace los making of a dirigir los casting
porque no te pones a dirigir
a mí me pareció maravilloso porque me
venía teniendo muchísimas horas de
laburo en la casting era de día tomaba
los castings de noche los editaba porque
estaba atravesando unas situaciones
adolescentes que también les pasa a los
adultos estaba atravesando los ataques
de pánico que no te dejaban vivir más de
bueno acá quizá la zona
ha sabido conocer y es muy lindo poder
decirles que la manera que de
sobrellevar los es encarando como esto
que les vengo diciendo encarando una
situación relativamente complicada como
es un ataque de pánico estaba dirigiendo
los comerciales y perdón los castings y
de repente le tenía que decir que tengo
como en la espalda entonces me tenía que
ir un poco la cabeza y eso de ponerlo en
palabras realmente y me hacía muy bien
entonces estando de días dirigiendo los
castings de noche citando los hasta las
6 de la mañana para tener que volver a
las 9 abrir la casting era me hizo
sacarme de ese lugar de angustia y
ansiedad y toda esa revolución hormonal
que tenía que me estaban llevando a no
sentirme del todo bien
así que vamos a llevar algo si algo me
pasó con la publicidad que empezamos a
filmar muchísimo fueron más de 10 años
dirigiendo publicidad a verlos fuimos a
los festivales de cannes del ojo de
iberoamérica de todas esas cuestiones y
si había algo que realmente me
interesaba de todo esto era un ser
humano que conocí y que gracias a dios
estuve metido en la publicidad por eso
no reniego tampoco por fue parte del
camino conocer a gonzalo vidal otro
gonzalo que de hecho esto lo tendría que
tratar en terapia porque yo me llamo
gonzalo gonzalo goya fue la persona que
me puso dirigir y éste también se llama
gonzalo por lo cual hay una cierta
cuestión narcisista que me persigue los
locos hacía ghosn abidal que estaba
y se repetía el patrón una vez más
armando prójimo prójimo es una agencia
escuela que trabaja en la villa la cava
y la villa la cava es la villa más
grande que hay en el país
esta foto es escalofriante porque este
es un paredón
esto es san isidro es uno de los barrios
con más poder adquisitivo que en la
provincia visto en la cava y está
pegadito así esto no está editado esto
funciona de esa manera y es terrible y
gonzalo el euro muchos años en vigo a
los polos sé que es una de las agencias
mundiales más grandes del mundo yo lo
conozco en cannes y me llamaba mucho la
atención porque el tipo más desprolijo
de todo se libra con dos camisas de
manga corta estábamos todos
simón y con todas esas cuestiones y ahí
me llamaba mucho la atención podido qué
tipo el seguro de sí mismo que viene acá
es el levantón premio y será con la
camisa de manga corta y saluda me
parecía bárbara esa cuestión este como
la terminó conociendo por una situación
muy similar y una vez más se repite el
patrón con el auto sea una casa agarré
un pozo y destroce una cubierta
lamentablemente digo bueno hayamos
seguro después dije no voy a ir yo como
ya adulto que soy voy a ir a la gomería
cambiar la cubierta y me encargaré esta
situación me dicen que rompió un par de
cosas más que tengo que esperar agarro
un diario de papel y lo encuentro a
gonzalo vidal en ese papel el había
desaparecido de los festivales
nunca me lo volví a cruzar porque estuvo
un par de cuestiones enfermo muy fuerte
le entraban a robar las agencias en
inundó la casa de pasión cosas muy feas
él vivía en san isidro y se cansó de
todo este mundo y dijo a ver qué pasa
así de este otro lado del paredón la
vida me trata de otra manera así con
héctor él
esa fue la que le pasó a él a mí me
pareció una gloria lo que estaba
haciendo
busque su contacto le dije te ahora de
mí que sabía que estaba ahí sí perfecto
nos vamos a conversar nos emocionamos él
también es un poco sensible como yo y él
tenía mucha escuela durante toda su vida
en agencia si las agencias son las que
redactan las ideas después pasan a una
productora y en las productoras se
llevan a cabo si así funciona esa
estructura a grandes rasgos entonces le
digo
cómo te puedo ayudar iniciaremos juntos
una productora acá dentro cuando mira la
publicidad me estaba con el mando habían
sido muchos años
qué hermoso momento para poder correr me
este lugar y encarar para acá entonces
hoy por hoy
y para tomar un poco de aire no me
dedico más a la publicidad me retiré de
la publicidad después de todos esos años
estoy metido dentro del prójimo y acá es
el momento donde hay altas
probabilidades en el quiebre porque esto
es hermoso lo que está pasando hoy es a
lo único que me dedico y es el lugar
donde a mi misión es volver a estar
cerca de mis ganas y de esa sensación
que yo tenía es decir a ver te voy a
tratar de no transgredir los las ganas
de los demás pero bien intentar ir
detrás de todas mis ganas cruce lo que
tenga que cruzar estas son cosas que
están pasando en prójimo hoy por hoy los
chicos filman publicidades volvió a la
publicidad pero bueno hay alguna manera
de volver a pasar al momento de tener
que producir videoclips y cualquier cosa
que se pueda generar audiovisual en la
parte productora en la parte de agencia
y por ejemplo se desarrollan marcas como
patton que estuvo 18 años preso
por no
a ver no sé si suma esto pero por no
haber delatado a otra persona
simplemente por tener códigos y no haber
tenido una embargo legal fuerte además
tuvo 18 años preso y es lo que más le
llamaba la atención dentro de la cárcel
era cómo se vestían les llamaba mucho la
atención los vestuarios fuera una cosa
muy muy random muy de zapatillas de
correr con un poncho eran cosas muy
llamativas y cuando nos comentó eso
pero dijimos lo que hizo fue juntar a
patton con un diseñador de primera línea
para traducir esas ideas y tratar de
bajarlas a lo material entonces hoy por
hoy button tiene su marca de ropa se
llama riego esta es su web y hoy patton
laura de esta manera y es hermoso lo que
pasa cuando estas cosas realmente cobran
el sentido sin materializar de chuck por
ejemplo que este chico del medio
hoy por hoy es productor musical tiene
su sello todos siguen bajo la contención
de prójimos pero todos siguen
desarrollándose atravesando todos los
que tuvieron que atravesar y hoy por hoy
también poder llegar a lo más cercano a
lo que tienen sus ganas feliz que es un
ser humano intachable hoy por hoy se
convirtió en una productora de cine que
es espectacular con sus 22 años
con unas posibilidades mucho menores a
las que tenía que el niño que no lavaba
la taza y hoy por hoy entre todos juntos
realmente hicieron que mis ganas y el
cine haya vuelto a tener sentido
focalizado absolutamente en el deseo que
tenía de que mis ganas se hagan realidad
atravesando todo lo que podía por eso de
alguna manera me parece que lo que está
bueno aprender es esto de desafiarse me
parece muy interesante nosotros nos
gustamos pero me parece que esa palabra
era linda desafiarse permanentemente a
ver uno no puede simplemente decir tengo
ganas de esto y el resto lo dejo no es
cuestión de encarar agarrada de muy muy
fuerte uno de todas esas ganas
me parece que digo ser genuino entre ese
concepto a tratar de redondear es lo que
más interesante me parece que donde uno
tiene que realmente focalizar su energía
a desafiarse permanentemente intentar ir
detrás de sus ganas este y tenerse mucha
paciencia sobre todo fíjense como todos
juntos existen y el doble un poquito de
paciencia quizás pudimos llegar a algo y
quizás además sea tan sencillo como
encarar y lavar simplemente una taza de
chocolate
[Aplausos]